INTRO:
With every passing year, it seems like more
and more physical retailers fall off the map
as they struggle to keep up with the online
revolution.
Retailers as big as JC Penny, J Crew, Neimen
Marcus, Pier 1 Imports, Toys R US, Fry's Electronics,
and even Sears have all filed for bankruptcy
or shut down completely.
And with the surge of the pandemic, it seemed
like this trend would only accelerate, and
that’s exactly what happened throughout
2020 as dying retailers completely collapsed.
But, as these weak retailers left the space,
the surviving retailers have emerged stronger
than ever before.
In fact, according to the US government, in
2021, retail sales grew by 18% while online
sales only grew by 14%.
Now, you could chalk this up to a rebound
from pandemic lows, and I’m sure that plays
a role.
But, this confirms that there are certain
products that people prefer to buy in person
even if they’re available online.
Otherwise, why would consumers have gone back
to physical retailers?
Also, given that a bunch of physical retailers
shut down during the pandemic, you would think
that it would be harder for the remaining
retailers to make a comeback, but that doesn’t
seem to be the case.
In fact, the National Retail Federation predicts
that 72% of US retail sales will still occur
in brick and mortar stores in 2024.
So, why are physical retailers making a comeback
and is this sustainable or just a fluke.
DELIVERY & RETURN:
One of the biggest strengths of physical retailers
is their delivery and return process.
While Amazon has continuously pushed down
delivery times from weeks to days to hours,
there’s often still quite a bit of friction
within these processes.
First of all, you have the package misdelivery
problem.
I’m sure all of us have received one of
our neighbors packages or our packages have
ended up at our neighbors house.
And oftentimes, you don’t even know where
your package went and it's just gone forever.
Whenever this happens, you have to file a
complaint with the retailer and UPS or Fedex,
and it’s just a massive headache.
In fact, I bet a lot of consumers don’t
even file lost package complaints especially
for cheap products just to avoid the hassle.
While this is simply a minor annoyance for
such cheap products, where this becomes a
serious problem is expensive products.
I don’t think any of us want to deal with
a new smartphone or laptop being delivered
to some random dude in the city.
Now of course, there is the option of requesting
a signed delivery for expensive products,
but this isn’t necessarily all that convenient.
You now have to spend your entire day at home
waiting for the delivery guy.
There’s also the problem of porch pirates
which is especially a problem within big cities.
In fact, over 10% of all packages disappear
without an explanation in the major US cities.
And given that most of us make at least one
online purchase every month, we’re talking
about dealing with at least one lost package
every year.
And then there’s the problem of returns.
Historically, returning products has been
one of the biggest hassles of the online shopping
experience.
26% of online shoppers say that they never
return an online order and 65% say that they
rarely return an online order.
This is quite ironic when you consider that
online return rates are still way higher than
brick and mortar return rates.
On average, shoppers return 5-10% of in store
purchases while shoppers return 15 to 40%
of online purchases.
This means that if most consumers weren't
too lazy to return online orders, this number
would be even higher.
Meanwhile, the successful physical retailers
have figured out how to perfectly combine
the online and physical shopping experiences
to offer the best of both worlds.
For example, with most stores, you can do
curbside pickup.
This is perfect if you wanna order something
online but don’t want to deal with delivery.
With curbside, you don’t even have to get
out of your car, but you can easily ensure
that your package doesn’t go to someone
else and that it’s the right product.
Also, it’s not a hassle to pick up the product
either if you plan it right.
You can just pick up your purchase when you
come back from work.
Similarly, if you don’t want the product,
you can simply drop it off in store the next
day after work.
Considering this, I believe a lot of Americans
will prefer curbside pickup even over home
delivery.
And as the convenience disparity between physical
and online shopping shrinks, physical retailers
will simply continue to make up ground.
ON DEMAND PURCHASES:
Aside from physical retailers shining in the
delivery and return categories, physical retailers
will continue to kill it when it comes to
on demand products like groceries.
While we have services like InstaCart and
WholeFoods home delivery, there’s no doubt
that these options are still extremely expensive.
And most Americans are unwilling to pay such
high delivery fees to simply receive everyday
goods like groceries.
While this has always been the case, it wasn’t
till recently that physical retailers have
started to leverage this advantage specifically
with curbside grocery delivery.
Now, this isn’t as advantageous for retailers
that only sell groceries, but this is extremely
helpful for mega retailers like Walmart, Target,
Sam's Club, and Costco who sell everything
under the sun.
Let’s say you need a new mouse.
Instead of ordering it from Amazon, why not
bundle it in with a Walmart grocery order
that you’re gonna pickup later that afternoon.
Not only would you receive the product earlier,
but you didn’t even have to do anything
extra.
After all, you would’ve gone to Walmart
to pick up your groceries whether or not you
ordered the mouse.
Another category that won't be going online
anytime soon is home improvement items.
If you’re installing a cabinet and run out
of screws, it makes a lot more sense to simply
make a quick trip to Home Depot or Lowes instead
of trying to order screws from Amazon.
Also, when you go to the store in person,
you can usually consult with Home Depot employees
who are generally quite knowledgeable.
Home Depot literally hires professional plumbers,
carpenters, and electricians to help customers
find products and give them tips on installation.
This has continued to be an invaluable service,
and if you don’t believe me, just take a
look at Home Depot stock.
While they have cooled down recently, they’re
stock has been going parabolic for years.
And as physical retailers continue to embrace
such on demand categories, we’ll likely
see consumers spend more money at these retailers
than ever before.
PRICE GAP:
On top of struggling with some inherent shortfalls,
online retailers have also been losing some
of the key advantages that made them better
in the first place like price.
About 10 years ago, a phenomenon called showrooming
was extremely common.
This is when consumers go to a store to check
out a product and then go home to purchase
the product online because it's cheaper.
While this made a lot of sense a decade ago,
it’s not as applicable today given that
physical retailers have managed to close the
price gap.
Some retailers even offer special in store
discounts which simply further incentivizes
in store shopping.
And this makes sense given that home delivery
is not cheap by any means.
Amazon had to run a money losing operation
for decades in order to eventually achieve
the economies of scale required to make home
delivery profitable.
And with time, Amazon has only increased the
cost of their prime subscription which now
sits at $140.
Aside from charging consumers for delivery,
Amazon also charges sellers for fulfillment
as well.
Amazon sellers generally have to pay $3 to
$6 for each item Amazon fulfills depending
on its size.
And as you would guess, sellers are just gonna
pass on this cost to consumers.
Now, you can’t really blame Amazon for these
fees given that their net margin is in the
single digits.
However, this gives physical retailers the
perfect opportunity to be competitive in terms
of price and that’s exactly what they’ve
done.
Walmart has actually overtaken Amazon in terms
of cheapness in several categories including
baby supplies, cleaning supplies, medicine,
and personal hygiene.
Amazon has maintained a lead in some other
categories such as make up, toys, and pet
food.
Meanwhile, in some categories such as snack
and food prices, Walmart and Amazon offer
identical prices to the penny.
So, clearly, it’s no longer a case of “It’s
always cheaper online.”
Usually, it depends on the product category,
and in the long term you’re not really going
to save money by choosing one or the other
in terms of product prices.
However, by shopping at physical retailers,
you don’t have to pay an annual subscription
fee or delivery fees, so it could actually
be cheaper to shop in person.
SHOPPING EXPERIENCE:
And finally as for the last factor driving
forward physical retailers is the shopping
experience itself.
Nowadays, people have gotten lazier than ever
before and have arguably gotten spoiled with
home delivery.
But, even despite this, there is something
special about in person shopping that you
just can’t get with online shopping.
I’m not talking about weekly grocery shopping
or essential purchases.
Rather, I’m talking about purchases that
you’ve been saving up for and are looking
forward to.
Take the iPhone for example.
8 years ago, I remember watching iJustine
camping outside of an Apple store to be one
of the first people in the world to get the
iPhone 6.
With the rise of online shopping, Apple has
made it possible to simply pre order the iPhone
and get it delivered to your house on the
day it’s released.
But, having the phone delivered to your doorstep
simply doesn’t have the same excitement
and satisfaction as buying it in store.
Now, that’s of course an extreme example,
but this applies to smaller purchases as well.
Buying shoes online isn’t the same as going
to a Nike store with your friends.
And I believe most consumers feel the same
way given that the majority of shoppers still
prefer to shop in store, and here’s the
reasons they cite for this preference.
33% of respondents to this survey suggest
that they prefer to view, touch, and interact
with physical products.
26% of respondents suggest that they enjoy
the overall shopping experience that a physical
location provides.
And 13% of respondents suggest that they like
the immediacy that in store shopping provides.
Hearing this, physical retailers have placed
a significant emphasis on improving the in
store experience from buffing up customer
support to making the entire process seamless.
And it seems like these improvements have
been working given that consumers still prefer
in store shopping in general.
THE CASE OF PHYSICAL RETAILERS:
Throughout this entire video, we’ve discussed
the various advantages of physical retailers
and the biggest shortfalls of online retailers.
And though online retailers do have their
disadvantages, I don’t want to give off
the impression that onlines retailers are
doing poorly.
People are spending more money than ever before
online, and this will only increase moving
forward.
But, with that being said, I also don’t
think that innovative retailers are going
anywhere either.
In fact, I think they perform tremendously
as well.
The problem with physical retailers 10 years
ago was that they were just simply trying
to replicate Amazon.
They simply threw together a website and started
shipping products to people’s houses.
This wasn’t very successful given that physical
retailers weren’t offering anything unique
or special in comparison to Amazon.
But over the years, the best retailers have
learned to leverage their physical locations
to offer something that Amazon can’t.
This includes a pick up and return convenience,
immediate availability, and a unique shopping
experience.
And as long as physical retailers continue
to lean into the factors that make them unique,
I don’t think they’ll be going anywhere.
But, that’s just what I think.
Do you guys prefer online shopping or in store
shopping?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you wish your packages
didn’t get lost in the mail on a regular
basis.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.